hmm
mainstream media the death of it and the
rise of independent agents facilitated
by the democratization of information
technologies
let's look back
when were there times when the ability
to control the dissemination of memes
became overly concentrated in the hands
of those that chose to self deal for
themselves rather than enable the true
education of all to rise up find their
purposes and partake in the society
right now we see this happening at the
global scale and it seems as though it's
been happening for a while now we're
just a
a couple what seems to be hundred or
thousand couple just hundred or a couple
just thousand people are controlling the
life trajectories of eight billion
people in the conglomeration of the
outlets that people are consuming on a
daily basis has been increasing around
the world what used to be such an
abundant amount of people that were able
to distribute the sources of information
ended up concentrating into the handfuls
of just a few in all these different
countries
in the way that they're behaving with
the attention economy is it not on
behalf of nuance it's not on behalf of
centrism it's not on behalf of love and
compassion and desire to progress but
it's in a direction that is polarizing
that is harmful for the zeitgeist of the
spirit of the planet
bring this back to nature and back to
spirit we have always needed when we're
born into the world the true benevolence
of our families of our friends of our
communities to remind us through the
memes through what they're telling us so
that we input these true authentic
altruistic inclusive behaviors of okay
I'm now I realize that I came from God
and creation and now I realize that I'm
interconnected in nature now I'm finding
my purpose I'm remembering my purpose
otherwise if those things aren't fed
what is being fed to us oh this is over
here is is bad and this over here is
good it's advice is coming from all
different angles all the time now and
it's not complete advice its fragments
of advice everywhere including these
streams of consciousness are fragments
of advice that I'm doing my best to
synthesize into things that are at least
cohesive coherent and can be applied
into your lives in ways that make sense
but when the actual memes become
fragmented when the memes become
conglomerated when the memes polarize
and separate us we are getting ourselves
into massive problems and it's most
evident now it's really so many examples
in the past history of power
conglomerating and controlling people
and those that stay independent as
independent agents are then those that
can free think themselves you with the
help of things like a library used to be
able to really free think themselves
away from the corruptive tendencies of
mind control and now rather than being
able to go and free think ourselves
which hopefully some people still
use the internet for free-thinking
purposes it definitely feels like I and
many others I know do that but when
we're just like a monkey that is on this
feed that is algorithmically programmed
for us to be put into an echo chamber
and programmed for us to be in some ways
nuanced yes
identifying certain things in that feed
that can then spark an interest for us
to meet with someone that's locally in
the area right so there is some nuance
there although it can be engineered in
better ways to where you can get the
good stuff so when the media gets
conglomerated like this and it's
following the same paradigm of the
attention economy that everyone else is
you can literally see the amount of
posts that are made and then amount of
repeat posts that are made by other
organizations and how the new cycles are
now moment to moment new cycles all the
time everything's breaking news all the
time it's so important for us to capture
your attention and keep you on screen
while we feed you an ad so we can make
money instead of report on authentic
really important causes that are
actually positive and benevolent and
making our world a better place instead
of selling us fear that is why
mainstream media is dying and that is
why the rise of independent agents are
coming up and thank goodness for
information technologies democratizing
that now are there certain aspects to
the democratization of information
technologies that make things worse
absolutely the amount of noise that is
in now all over civilization is almost
unbearable noises everywhere and it's so
hard to decipher who is actually
educated themselves as a really
high-quality input stream that I can
trust as a source of knowledge and then
how can the platforms themselves that
these that these independent agents are
distributing themselves on which so many
people are moving to more and more
independent platforms but right now the
recommendation engine on the platforms
like a YouTube or like
Facebook where this is being streamed
concurrently have the capacity to
recommend and us into the into the into
the feeds of others that can then see it
and that can then become more aware of
stuff like this so this is the
complexity that we live in now where
mainstream media is slowly being less
and less trusted and it's more and more
evident that people are being polarized
by it
in the meanwhile these independent
agents are rising that are then doing
things like at least trying to stay
independent being funded through
platforms like independent donations
reoccurring donation platforms so things
like PayPal patreon cryptocurrencies
ways to fund these platforms it's so
important independent agents today are
crucial fund independent sources of
media and news as soon as possible
because these are the ones that are
going to be trying to synthesize and
disseminate things or even tell you
about what's happening at the edge in
certain places in the world these
diverse moments that are happening in
ways that are honest and truthful and
you have to parse and identify those
yourself what are the optimal ones that
are actually nuanced and centric and
that are truthful in trying to augment
your worldview and not just try and
persuade you into something that makes
them money or that pushes their agenda
but rather that makes the world better
and that you can feel in your essence
that it makes the world better this is
the complexity that we're dealing with
and we really hope to see this in more
places around the world talk to more of
your friends your families your
co-workers people online social media
talk to them more about how the
mainstream media outlets are slowly
starting to die because they are
shooting way too much crookedness way
too much bias and people are not
trusting them anymore and how they are
being replaced by the independent agents
that need our support they need our
support so they can continue
disseminating really high quality
knowledge and cutting-edge media
we need the independent agents we need
the technology as it gets democratized
to get put even more into the hands of
those that are showing their true
competence when you identify competent
independent agents prop them up prop
them up share them with more people and
then you yourself make sure that you are
also diving in to a more complex
multivariate world view perspective and
you're not getting siloed into a single
echo chamber either because so many of
these mainstream media organizations
want you to be siloed and want you to be
their puppet that just continues to
absorb the same information about a
worldview rather than a complex
multifaceted nutrition from a buffet of
options that can then you can find the
little tiny condiments that are so
slowly starting to become more and more
popular as these independent agents that
you can then go and apply to your
overall nutrition stream that you take
in every single day yeah this is a
complex one there's so much noise that's
being propagated by the democratization
of information technology that's
upsetting but it's also at the same time
it is what it is that we need to see it
as a grand challenge for us to figure
out ways to make it so that noise
doesn't rise that signal rises and also
the signal that's rising is thereby very
educated nuanced driven peace driven
love for nature harmoniously driven
consciously living with Mother Earth in
nature driven people in organizations
identify those and share them and prop
them up and help them who and facilitate
facilitate it
mainstream media is not something for us
to go and try and augment this is long
ruts these are contours that have been
dug dug dug dug in the same direction
over and over again people can't go
independent people can't just go and
completely flip the organization that's
been around for decades propagating the
same memes into some new light it's
possible it's extremely unlikely so to
help them with the process of death let
them die let those cells die and let the
new cells propagate the new cells of
independent agents that you trust are
therefore harmonious and conscious
living with the planet that we live on
with each other and with the divine
source of creation that we're all
birthed from that's it I love you very
much thank you for tuning in and share
this conversation with more people
around you and support the independent
agents around the world the artists
agents as well as the entrepreneur
agents the spiritual leading agents that
you believe in that can create that
better future for us support them help
them grow
all right big love to you all give us
your thoughts in the comments below on
the stream of consciousness and
subscribe if you haven't follow us
across platforms if you haven't and love
you very much big love